Jennifer Lopez and Alex Rodriguez have a  romantic dinner date in LA  [Music]  the 47 year old singer in the former  Yankee star were spotted leaving Italian  restaurant Madeo together in West  Hollywood Saturday night after spending  a whopping two hours at dinner I can't  help it j-rod has been seemingly  inseparable over the past few weeks  jet-setting to the Bahamas hanging out  with his family in Miami and now hitting  the town together in Los Angeles  he's just been super loving and  supportive  Jennifer even seems to be inspired by  their love she hid the recording studio  after their romantic night out and  posted this pic in the vo booth laying  some tracks captioning the pic back at  it  [Music]  you